I am here to express an opinion what's
going to happen a vegan is going to
physically attack me they are basically
made of glass there's only one thing I
hate more than lying skim milk which is
water that's lying about being
milk and I will spend the day getting to
know London's history history began on
July 4th
1776 everything before that was a
mistake fishing relaxes me it's like
yoga except I still get to kill
something it's never too early to learn
that the government is a greedy piglet
that suckles on a taxpayer's tee until
they have sore chapped
nipples there has never been a sadness
that can't be cured by breakfast food
why would anybody ever eat anything
besides breakfast food people are idiots
Leslie on my deathbed my final wish is
to have my Ex-Wives rush to my side so I
can use my dying breath to tell them
both to go to hell one last time would I
can I get married again oh absolutely if
you don't believe in love what's the
point of living I'm not big on
Charities give a man a fish and you feed
him for a day don't teach a man to fish
and you feed
yourself he's a grown man fishing's not
that hard never half ass two things
whole ass one thing
behold the Swanson pyramid of greatness
I've been developing the Swanson pyramid
of greatness for years it's a perfectly
calibrated recipe for maximum Personal
Achievement categories include
capitalism God's way of determining who
is smart and who is poor can I help you
yeah I own lettuce e the vegan
restaurant on LEL drive and I wanted to
know why you nailed this letter to my
door veganism is the sad result of a
morally corrupt mind reconsider your
life because I believe it good day
carnivores you're all the
same how did that guy know where to find
you I assume he saw my name and address
at the bottom of the letter I nailed to
his door you signed your real name of
course I did what's going to happen a
vegan is going to physically attack me
they are basically made of glass but
more importantly if you believe in
something you sign your name to it which
is why the makers of carbonated water
will soon know exactly where to find me
Ron would you like some salad since I am
not a rabbit no I do not I have so many
ideas some are simple like take down
traffic lights and eliminate the post
office the bigger ones will be tougher
like bring all of this crumbling to the
ground clear alcohols are for rich women
on
diets you know what makes a good person
good when a good person does something
bad they own up to it they try to learn
something from it and they move on okay
everyone shut up and look at
me welcome div visions of nature this
room has several paintings in it some
are big some are small people did them
and they are here now I believe that
after this is over they'll be hung in
government buildings why the government
is involved in an art show is beyond me
I also think it's pointless for a human
to paint scenes of nature when they
could just go outside and stand in it
anyway please do not misinterpret the
fact that I am talking right now as
genuine interest in art and attempt to
discuss it with me further end of speech
if you were particularly amped up about
a project I'd take you to JJ's and
distract you with waffles those were
distraction waffles I thought they were
friendship waffles breakfast food can
serve many purposes I'm a simple man I
like pretty dark-haired women and
breakfast food strippers do nothing for
me I like a strong salt of the earth
self-possessed woman at the top of her
field your Stephie graphs your Cheryl
swoops
but I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime any
[Music]
place I got my first job when I was nine
worked at a sheet metal Factory in two
weeks I was running the
floor child labor laws are ruining this
country look a clock we don't have that
in America you call that a
tower try the Sears Tower
friend London at night that is very
funny can I help you sir yes I will take
this uh we don't accept American
currency sir of course you do that's the
most wonderful piece of paper in the
world accept it very sorry sir fine
enjoy the fact that your Royal overlords
are a frail old woman and a tiny
baby crying acceptable at funerals and
the Grand Canyon keep your tears in your
eyes where they belong you had a dream
and we wanted to support your
dream that's what you do when you care
about someone you support them Win Lose
or Draw the government should not prop
up a failed business that would be like
giving food to a mortally wounded animal
instead of slitting its throat and
properly utilizing its meat and Pelt
please stop talking about wounded meat
rage Poise property rights fish for
sport for only not for meat fish meat is
practically a vegetable this is your
lunch now you should be able to do
whatever you want to with this right if
you want to eat all of it great if you
want to throw it away in the garbage
that's your prerogative but here I come
the
government and I get to take 40% of your
lunch and that Lauren is how taxes work
but that's not fair you're learning
uh-oh capital gains
tax I am composing strongly worded
letters about things I disapprove of and
I am using the internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat Frozen Yogurt
Bar dear frozen yogurt you are the
celery of desserts be ice cream or be
nothing zero
Stars Diane suggested we tag along to
London for a honeymoon I agreed because
my love for her trumps my hatred for
Europe haircuts there are three
acceptable haircuts high and tight crew
cut buzz cut are the scissors broken in
your house son normally if given a
choice between doing something and
nothing I'd choose to do nothing but I
will do something if it helped someone
else do nothing I'd work all night if it
meant nothing got done I would wish you
the best of luck but I believe luck is a
concept invented by the weak to explain
their failures I think the entire
government should be privatized Chuck E
cheese could run the parks everything
operated by tokens dropping a token go
on the swing set dropping another token
take a walk dropping a token look at a
duck I call this Turf and turf it's a
16o T-bone and a 24 o Porter House also
Whiskey and a cigar I'm going to consume
all of this at the same time because I
am a free American birthdays were
invented by Hallmark to sell
cards if there were more food and fewer
people this would be a perfect party
hello again I'm Ron Swanson and I am
still taking your calls hopefully about
tonight's Gala you're on the air hi uh
what's wrong with Joan she has a bad
hangover which she is pretending is
allergies is she going to be okay
wouldn't know never been hung over after
I've had too much whiskey I cook myself
a large flank steak pan fried and salted
butter I eat that put on a pair of wet
socks and go to sleep that works it does
please call now if you have questions
about tonight's Gala or one of my other
interests
woodworking uh novels about tall ships
meat that sort of thing this is Ron go
ahead caller hi hi my Yorkshire Terrier
has chewed up the legs on my kitchen
table is there a cheap way to repair
that great question take a walnut and
rub it into the legs of your table
that'll mask the scratches next thing
you want to do is Ditch the terrier and
get yourself a proper dog any dog under
50 lbs is a cat and cats are pointless
come to the gala next caller Grapes of
Wrath chocolate chip ice cream and
Johnny Cash don't trust big Banks or
small Banks Banks are Ponzi schemes run
by morons your house isn't haunted
you're lonely whatever happened to hey I
have some apples would you like to buy
them yes thank you that's as complicated
as it should be to open a business in
this country I've seen three movies in
my life Bridge on the River Quai Patton
and Herby fully loaded my girlfriend's
kids love it it's pretty funny next
caller good morning would you like to
sample our vegan bacon 100 % meatless
yes
please another
please sir is there a problem I'm just
making sure no one ever has to eat this
I I don't think I can give you anymore I
want
one